same old friends here this is wonderful
audience no students today
Oh - okay great I wish we had more
students because there's questions from
the students are always interesting on
the other hand the questions from you
guys are great and I'm very happy with
what we did a couple of weeks ago I was
since you mentioned passwords and time
sharing and stuff like that the Corbett
Oh memorial event on Monday afternoon
and evening was wonderful really
extraordinary everybody from the old
multics days was still alive it was
there and a lot of other folks that have
been fighting this battle for so many
years that would be good that's good
so what I want to do today is give two
talks that are completely different what
you heard three weeks ago the first one
the thunderclap talk is is really
largely due to Theo in Cambridge and I
would point out that that this talk and
the other the second half of it are
funded by DARPA and a little bit of the
UK which Theo managed to get a little
grant from the the British government
and there's a pieces of under additional
funding from for students for example we
have three or four students funded by
Google or arm or Microsoft or whatever
in Cambridge and I've got a wonderful
team of folks in Cambridge who are
really the ones who are driving all of
this thunderclap stuff and the hardware
stuff and what I may have a little bit
of time to talk about is what Gerry
our hardware architecture can do for
thunderclap I can't get into that at the
moment because there's a lot of stuff
that's in flux and that part of the
project is protected by
controlled unclassified information
which is annoying so we have to get
slides approved and we have to get
papers approved and all that stuff I'm
going to ramble through a lot of the
thunderclap issues as as you suggested
you've got a dongle that you stick in
here which your into your laptop which
purports to be a charger it's going to
charge your your battery for you how do
you know you have any idea what the hell
you're sticking into your laptop and as
you will see the answer is you don't
have a clue so let us get into that the
standard here is pluggable peripherals
docking stations things that used to be
way inside they're now outside you've
got folks building systems where the
device drivers are in user space like an
SEO for you've got stuff that typically
in your laptops and your cell phones
there are something like two dozen
devices microcontrollers clocks whatever
most of which have direct memory access
to your main processors and those are
all proprietary they're undocumented you
have absolutely no idea what the hell is
going on so this is the problem that
we're going to be looking at Thea ask
what can an adversary do and and the
answer is just about anything
peripherals are more weakly defended
than the main system and they are
springboards to further attacks and they
give the users and the system
administrators the opportunity to do all
sorts of horrible things that they don't
realize they're doing and of course
experimentation exfiltration and all
that and supply chain where you really
don't know what you're getting
these micro controllers that are
embedded in your laptops and cell phones
are in fact doing something malicious so
the fundamental problem is one that we
spent we've spent about four years
playing with this and I'll give you a
quick rundown on what happened I think
four maybe five years ago yes we got a
little seedling from DARPA to study this
problem of what what what does it look
like inside and we would we did some
digging and we found these two deist
dozen or two dozen microcontrollers and
we found all kinds of stuff deeply
inside I'm not going to talk about you
got them in yon but but the Google
project 0 which started around what four
years ago may be discovered one of the
things that that was particular to a
Wi-Fi microcontroller and all these
slides are online so you'll have access
to that I'm not going to talk so much
about his work but more about ours and
so we started out just looking at this
thing and then along came the second
project from the MTO part of DARPA and
what they asked for was they want to
risk five cherry and they want a
possibility of an armed cherry of some
sort we were already doing some armed
cherry stuff for 64-bit in in the first
project and there's something that I
can't talk about what you say a non
specification of a non prototype that
are miss looking at and that's that's
about all I can say about that one for a
32-bit sherry arm the human factors are
enormous there's a huge disconnect
between the thing that it looks like a
charger and is in fact something
completely different
there's there's just a lot of confusion
here and the thing we want to get into
is the
called iommu which is trying to do for
IO what the MMU is doing for memories
and we started out looking at IOM news
and from the peripheral point of view
rather than the microcontroller embedded
and we found that each peripheral has
potentially an enormous amount of
potential access so we started telling
Microsoft about this three years ago
their first reaction was this is not on
our business model it's not a problem a
year later we gave them the revised
paper that actually showed what their
problems were in Windows 7 and 8 there
is no iommu and Windows 10 home there
wasn't one in the early stages and in
Windows 10 Enterprise there is one but
it's not enabled by default and in home
Pro and later on 18:03 and beyond there
is a little bit of kernel protection in
fact they responded to what we had told
them and they did make some changes and
and you'll see that in a moment
we we told Mac that they had a problem
and we showed them what it was and they
ran out and they got to ten point eight
point two of us and that in fact solved
one of the problems there's still a
bunch that that haven't been resolved
yet but we were a diligent and in
telling everybody about what their
problems were and giving them a lot of
time to respond so in three iterations
to the paper we finally got it accepted
the first two times we submitted it the
referees said one referee said this is a
fantastic paper it's breaking all kinds
of new ground the other two referees I
don't understand this stuff
I don't know anything about this but I'm
an expert in the area so I'm gonna
reject this paper so we the third time
around we actually got the paper
accepted and that's the paper that that
I'm basically presenting field slides on
linux i ôm you was not enabled by
default after 4.2.1 it's enabled for
Thunderbolt devices but not PCI other
other kinds of devices and the mappings
in fact are specific to a device
so for FreeBSD it's not again not
enabled by default and there is no
there's no Thunderbolt hot-plug only
devices attached at power on are enabled
which is a little bit of a help
this means somebody can't walk up to
your processor and stick in the the
nasty thing okay now what we've done is
we've actually built a thing called
thunderclap which is that device that
you plug into a USB C port and it pretty
much takes over the system if if you
worry about the internals of the
microcontrollers I will again talk a
little bit about that but not enough but
the the basic attitude there is we're
going to put a capability based
interposer which will work dandy in a
cherry system which we'll talk about in
the second half of the talk and that
that might in fact mediate all of these
otherwise unrestricted DMA accesses now
I want to make one point a lot of theö
in fact thought that this was a a new
problem and I pointed out no no we
recognize that in multics in 1965
because the G IOC was a coprocessor
input/output and it had basically the
potential of total access to all memory
but it was configured in such a way that
was hard hard well not hard wired but it
was programmed in a way that was very
difficult to change into certain
registers that you could share with
absolute addresses rather than with
virtual addresses and so we recognized I
was part of the multics thing in 65 and
it was clear that this was a problem
and it was clear that we were not going
to address it in a system that was
designed for a computer center that had
locked doors and no access to to the
processor so you're not going to get it
in reprogram the G IOC and it was it was
not accessible on the internet because
there was no internet I'm reminded of
the story of Robert Morrison and the
internet worm where Microsoft said gee
we're so good that this never bothered
us of course it was only going at at a
particular Linux operating system so
they were immune without thinking about
it so that was a funny statement from
Microsoft saying oh yeah well then they
also discovered the Internet but that
was another thing so here we have this
this platform I'm not going to go into
the hardware and the software in any
great detail but it's basically FPGA
attached is attached by a PCIe to the
port and so the idea is that it presents
the thunderclap device as a real
functional PCIe device and it is
plausible enough to allow driver
attachment it's it's perfectly capable
of performing all of the correct
interactions with the iommu to open
windows send and receive packets and so
on and the the bottom line there is
it is a Turing machine basically that
has access to - pretty much everything
in your system there's a bunch of
versions of it the current version is
aria 10 with hard arm core running
ubuntu it iterated as you can see
through various versions and this is the
current version the board looks like
this and that's the area 10 SOC
development kit and then there's the the
boards and I don't want to get into that
because that will take up too much time
because I want to get a clock here
that's good
ok hardware miscellanea this is Theo
being Theo talking about docks and OS
images and and the the fiddling around
with the cards and all that stuff and
the basics packets which you can add
tree structure using switches transport
layer packets
both ends are generating tlps is
bi-directional and self-description
discovery by a configuration registers
stored on the device so it's basically
probing and figuring out what's going on
and taking advantage of it the interface
let's see I think you can read that
slide faster than I can speak it
and then TLP generation and finally they
a team you code base emulating and
figuring out what's happening
major is major surgery to strip out the
majority of commuted to get this to work
cleanly and then Theo dug into the TLP
handling okay so as far as the internal
networking is going on it's the back end
is slurp and he says so we could have
plumbed fake a fake Nick through the
real Nick on arm but it wasn't even
needed for the attacks that we were
creating so it was gratuitous
weaponizing chemo and fun with
thunderclap there was having a ball for
a couple of years here three years I
guess playing with all this pointers
exposed to Nick Goethe 4kb
page granularity you can change the
pointer and take control the same
process works for FreeBSD he's watching
the pages exposed to the Nick and is
able to dump anything he wants and this
I think gives you the idea that this
little dongle is a pretty amazing
creature it has some fascinating
abilities so back in 2016 we started
talking to Microsoft I mentioned already
they announced that Windows 10 18:03
will enable the iommu that doesn't mean
they solved the problem but it means it
will be much better than it has been in
the past
Apple fix the vulnerability that we
report it to them in ten point twelve
point four and that was released fairly
quickly once we we showed them the
problem Linux says Intel enabled I
your Thunderbolt devices it's disabled
for 80s for thunderbolt and their
security team says it's a hard problem
to solve in general I think that should
be obvious to you at this point that
this is a problem that's been around a
long time like buffer overflows and all
these other problems that have been
around and are not solved there that
one's easier to solve but this one is I
think rather piggy because of all the
foibles that go on but it's even piggy
err when you start thinking about the
embedded microcontrollers that are as I
say proprietary where nobody knows what
the hell they're going on and they're
not documented and they're dis thrown in
there we got a clock and we got this we
got that and oh let's put in another
microcontroller for the dysfunction and
if there are two dozen of them and you
try to do a census you lose before you
even begin so that's the situation there
we have further engagements with Intel
HP our Microsoft and others Apple Google
interested as well and yet there's still
a lot that we could do and fortunately
the second project is the one that is
funding it now whereas the first one is
the one that started out and so I think
in his spare time Theo is continuing to
to play with us now he has it's open
sourced and he there's a website that IO
website where all of this stuff is up
and he says it's pretty hard to use for
somebody who's just wants to play around
with it
it takes a while but he's trying to make
it more more usable now conclusions on
thunderclap it's a flexible platform for
IO security research and it's leading us
to new
Solutions in fact it's leading us to a
capability based solution that we
believe will vastly simplify the problem
at President it needs a skilled operator
as some sharp edges remain the published
paper is online and the last bullet is
interesting our work has had
considerable real-world impact including
what is noted on slide 25 I added that
and in addition since I gave the talk as
of early September we are delighted to
report that the new USB standard number
four is in fact adopting most of the
recommendations of the Thunder
thunderclap paper so I think DARPA feels
a milady I'm leaving out a lot who who's
they oh yes yes yes they're not solving
the problem okay yeah I mean we are
trying to solve the problem but if you
know anything about security there are
no solutions that are guaranteed so
you're doing the best you can and I
think they're going to be doing a lot
better with the u.s. before then they
have been in the past but I think this
is a very high step that has to be taken
to to get to the next step is it's a
it's a big leap and the US before is a
step forward definitely okay um let me
see what relative relative background on
on the cherry mitigation that were just
starting to deal with as I said we have
support from both mi2 O&M Tuohy DARPA
and British funding there is a website
Thunder thunderclap Daioh which theo
runs
and I think we're believing that we can
come a long way toward a capability
based solution that were just beginning
to firm up and then specify and it's
clearly hardware/software a problem it's
one that you can't solve and hardware
alone you can't solve it in the software
alone but you can come much closer if
the hardware is supporting it and we
believe we're going to be doing that
yeah this is true well everything we're
doing is open-source at this point
except for the connection with arm and I
would say that everything here is dual
use and the foreign nationals are going
to pick up on this immediately and say
oh great we can break all these systems
our I'll come to come to this at the
very end we're actually getting now
getting some real buy-in into tech
transfer so this could could wind up in
your laptops and cellphones in a few
years
yeah it could be anything it could be
could be a sick you could be almost
anything could be a gigantic computer
but you don't need it that is a very
interesting argument I once had a
contract from NSA which was issued in
one day I got the eff statement of work
in the morning I sent the proposal in
that day and they came back with the
contract that afternoon the challenge of
that was to write a report that shows
that if it's in hardware it's more
secure more reliable more trustworthy
than if it's in software I came up with
the opposite conclusion that that is not
true and I think they were very unhappy
they wanted to believe that that just
because you you have crypto boxes that
are built by the agency well I think the
that was demonstrated by met Blaise when
he broke the Clipper Chip escrow thing
by making a trivial modification to the
law enforcement access field and just
blew the whole system out of the water
so I think the answer there is you don't
want to count your chickens until you
have done something with them that I
don't talk about I think yes if you put
it in hard work it's going to be less
less manipulable unless it's in firmware
if you put it in software you'd
understand a chance because the
operating systems you're putting it on
err fundamentally flawed and the whole
purpose of cherry is to try well one of
the purposes is to make
the use of C and C++ memory safe as a
result of the hardware and if you use a
memory safe language than different set
of problems but I think the the answer
to that is yes it should be this should
be done in hardware and that means a lot
of people are going to have to build
something into their hardware Intel has
to do some massive changes I think their
hardware
I think arm has taken a very interesting
view on this and that is that they came
back to us and said you know you've got
this compartmentalization that mechanism
that I'm going to talk about in a moment
if you use that and you had an
identifier for the compartment you you
have a long leg up on solving the DNA
problem so that was a very very useful
observation on their part this is a
slide that you can't read but the the
essence was we had using FPGA s which
yes it's much faster to get it going we
had a running processor in one year on
FPGAs and that enabled us to do all this
other stuff so there's an enormous I'm
not going to go through the slide but
the point is that the last the first two
years were really the research platform
and the prototype architecture the
second the next two were hybrid model of
being able to run legacy code in a
sandbox and have it not be able to
clobber the operating system or the
hardware and the compartmentalization
model and then in the last the four
years after that we were started dealing
with the cherry ABI and
the linker and the the connection with
arm and for the charity arm 64bit and in
the last two years when we've picked up
this other funding from from the other
side of DARPA we're worried about risk v
and temporal safety and and formal
proofs there's another project actually
which is formally proving the
correctness of the instructions that
architecture with respect to a bunch of
capability properties that are
fundamental to security and
trustworthiness in general so that's
that's sort of where we've been and
where we're going
here's a picture of the read of the
actual nine years of the Gerry spec
we've just published version 7 which is
up on the Cambridge website it's three
hundred and whatever pages I guess it's
over four hundred and eleven inch pages
and and it's three hundred and sixty
something and British longer pages it's
very detailed and it goes in to not only
the the sherry mips is what we started
out with I'll come to that in a minute
but also the cherry arm 64-bit extension
to arm v8 and which was done largely by
arm as a prototype just to see if it
would work and that we gave them a lot
of support and then now the 32-bit and
64-bit Jerry risk five so there are
different versions the specifications
that parameterised so you can do 32-bit
or 64-bit with the same spec and that's
that's helpful so we're actually proving
that these some of these specs satisfied
the basic capability properties
an unfortunate enon bypass ability
monotonicity where you can't in any way
extend the the range of your virtual
address space and you can't change the
privileges you can increase the
privileges and that stuff is going on in
a third project so we have the moment
three projects I think I'm going to talk
a little bit about the the UK RI stuff
which is the British funding for some
additional tech transfer work which is
still under contract but it looks as if
it's going to happen and and basically
we got protection model we've got the
implementation in at least three
different modes of mips was a easy one
to use because it was open source and we
had a specification that somebody had
already done for a 32-bit mips and so
somebody at Cambridge crafted a 64-bit
version of it and that became the
baseline for all of this work in the
last nine years
cherri mitigates vulnerabilities in C
and C++ Robert Watson had that had the
view that if we can get rid of all of
these memory management problems in C
and C++ in Hardware it would be a great
thing and at this British UK our eye
thing Microsoft actually came out and
said well 70% of their their flaws our
memory management problems and this
thing seems to solve this architecture
seems to solve a lot of them so that's
encouraging that that says that we are
we're heading towards something that is
useful in the in the C plus C and C++
world now the question comes up every
now and then what about if you had
rest or a memory safe language why would
you need cherry well Terry does a lot
more than than just the memory
management stuff and one of the things
that we're doing in the second project
is the notion of of trying to remediate
a bunch of common weakness examples
exemplars the the MTO 4mt out folks came
up with a bunch of classes of these
things which they thought would be
illustrative if we can show that the
cherry actually mitigates those in some
reasonable way then then it's a it's a
win it looks it looks good now
unfortunately the the number of common
vulnerabilities is over 130,000 now and
the number of that were required to
mitigate is relatively small so the
question which is an open question at
this point is what what what do we do
with all this other stuff what are we
what what percentage of the hundred and
thirty thousand open vulnerabilities at
the moment can can this architecture
deal with and we don't know yet this is
something that we're looking at
seriously the the compartmentalization
mechanism makes good use of the of the
capability hardware and as I mentioned
you can run legacy object code in a
sandbox you can run you can take a C or
C++ program and recompile it and change
all of the pointers into capability
calls if you want or some of them you
can annotate
the source code and say which ones do
you want to be capability calls and then
you could partition it into different
compartments so that you can solve some
of the internal problems and the
compartmentalization is also useful you
know in a broader scale not just as as a
fine great thing but as a coarse grain
thing where you are compartmentalizing
all the apps on your cell phone or
whatever each one is completely separate
from everything else except in the knee
cases that they have to share so that's
that's sort of the the basic there
cherry enforces protection semantics for
pointers and I mentioned monotonicity
and and permissions and balance and and
I didn't mention provenance basically a
capability cannot be derived unless it
is derived from an existing capability
and the provenance is maintained so you
actually keep track of the fact that it
was derived from a legitimate capability
and you can't fabricate them you can't
Forge them you can't create why not
yeah that's not an issue we saw it's an
interesting question we started out with
256 capabilities 256 bit capabilities in
in the cherry myths and some of our
industrial folks say yeah it's too big
can't do that so we have a compression
scheme to compress it down to 128 bit
capability on a 64 bit machine and the
the limitations it turns out are almost
negligible the the compression uses
something that looks like a
floating-point representation and as
long as your thing is of appropriate
size and the things are on the
even boundaries or whatever you have to
do that is not a problem so we we have
played with with 64-bit capabilities on
a 32-bit machine we can we can do that
as well and we do have some graduate
students are writing thesis on the the
variants that's one of them there's one
of the graduate student at the moment
working on use after free and things of
that nature and basically we've got
about eight nine PhD is already out of
the nine years and we've got I think six
in the hopper right now at Cambridge and
they're probably 20 25 people in
Cambridge working on on this with with
the various funding that we have for the
three projects and and that doesn't
count the formal methods stuff to prove
the properties about the the various
variants of the cherry architecture
Peter sue at Cambridge is the leader of
the formal method Stefan he has his own
pile of funding from the British
government he already had that to do a
formal specification of the the arm
version seven arm gave him permission to
do that and he area under Sigma job on
that so at that point is easy leap
forward and I said we're playing with
with all kinds of different options and
the grad students are having a ball
there they're amazing doing absolutely
wonderful things so I have taken 40
minutes and there's a slide on the
compartmentalization where you can have
control sharing among the different
pieces and then this is the killer slide
so there's a lot of problems that we
haven't solved yet this is a nine-year
effort thus far and I don't know what is
the average time of getting stuff into
into production into real real Hardware
ten years twelve years what is the worst
case I always double oh yeah yeah all
right but the worst case it never gets
into into the world real world and this
stuff seems to have some serious
potential for that at the moment but yet
there are all these things that like
formal proofs of software properties can
we prove that the Cape DLL the cherry
LLVM which understands the hardware and
uses the capabilities when you compile a
pointer and it converts it into a
capability it uses that very
constructively can we start to prove
things from the hardware up to the the
kernel and up into the compiler and so
on that's all something that we'd like
to do in the future so I see maybe
there's another five ten years of
research here yeah we'll see I have no
idea there's a great deal of work on the
debugger
there's even work on a debugger for for
risk 5 on that on the actual platform
[Music]
one of my guys is writing a
specification for that that were
involved with the risk 5 community
[Music]
we have a formal specification of the
risk by a baseline and we have a formal
specification of the risk the cherry
risk five and that's the what what Peter
Seoul is using to do properties about
that and on and on and on let's see is
there anything else there that is worth
talking about
compartmentalization we one of the grad
students
eight years ago built a little tool for
helping you and your compiling of how do
you partition up something in such a way
that oh I didn't turn mine off either
and that is a tool that we've got to
come back to and figure out how do we
help programmers system programmers take
the the optimal advantage of of the
compartmentalization that's a tricky
tricky problem but the the tool is
called soap as Oh Oh a P SS o aap sorry
and that was a lovely piece of work
I think Robert and and some other folks
who have been trying to use it in other
projects and there was a thing called
Tesla which is a real-time there was
little sequential machine that's looking
for bad things inside the hardware and
that is another Avenue where I guess
Robert as a another DARPA project that
is actually using that constructively so
there there are a lot of potential
spin-offs here that look like they're
worth pursuing
and the debate of the basic question is
is is this really going to happen
the
talks about the the you Kri effort which
you some of you may have read about in
the press the e times that an article
and the register had an article and this
was the the notion that the British
government decided to pony up some real
big euros I'm sorry big pounds
did I say euros that's weird would
breaks it going on yeah and then that
there's matching funds from industry and
Microsoft an arm and a bunch of other
folks are are interested in all that so
there's there's some real effort at the
moment that looks as if it's going to
happen that might help bring all this to
in the real world so let me stop at that
point and see if I can get some
questions out of you guys that that are
worth answering now let me get you on
mic this time less
so in your list of projects I didn't see
anything about user interface
my experience with capability systems is
the underneath can be real secure but it
can be too easy to give away too much
authority unless the UI is good I said
UI not a bi an answer to that in the
sense of the you're building a an
environment that makes it look like
they're hardware and you're dealing I
meant something like inadvertently
sharing a file readwrite when you meant
to share a read-only that's a UI issue
to the confused deputy problem for
example give you an example Marc
Stiegler developed this concept wizzy
wish what you see is what you share so
if you're viewing a file readwrite and
you share it it gets shared readwrite
and if you're viewing the file read-only
it's you'd read to get shared read-only
very clever and I got it wrong about
half the time so that's an example of
needing research on the UI level we do
have the example that you can't read and
write
read and execute basically this is read
and write not read and execute but I
wanted to say I wanted to share a file
with you where you could send me your
comments but you couldn't edit the file
directly and I would inadvertently share
it with you where you could so that but
I need a way to express that policy and
that's exactly and that's what I'm
talking about you good well yeah it
should be on that list you're right ok
we forgot about that one
you had a problem with iommu stuff that
was a pointer in a block or something
that look like a simple software problem
what am I missing what let me start from
the bottom up what you're missing is the
fact that there are 24 microcontrollers
all of which have direct memory access
basically uncontrolled okay how do you
how do you manage that how do you
prevent them from taking over your
entire system how do you prevent it the
Chinese from putting a Trojan horse in
one of the little widget
microcontrollers that that that
everybody's going to put into their
computer because it's the cheapest one
and and it seems like everybody said oh
it's wonderful yes you use it this is
not a software problem this is a
hardware problem
yeah I was trying to solve the plug it
in problem yeah it's the same problem in
a sense whether you plug it in or
whether it's already there it's the same
problem it's still a direct memory
access that is uncontrolled doesn't that
doesn't that make sense yeah but it
doesn't work now if you had a better
iommu you still can't solve the problem
for the embedded microcontrollers that's
not its purpose
yeah good question what is the overhead
most of the capability stuff is is 2%
roughly there's some worst cases
occasional worst cases that get up a
little bit more but it's not noticeable
and if it's a simple processor and it's
not as complicated as as an Intel
processor and you don't have to worry
about speculative execution and things
of that nature as much but you still
have to worry about them this is one
that's one of the things we have written
and report on the overhead is of the
compartmentalization is not significant
each paper that is written we got about
40 papers in the nine years deals with
what is the overhead of the particular
piece of the mechanism that you're
talking about and it varies but but in
an average it's something on the order
of 2% and I would think if if we're
dealing with new hardware in a couple of
years it's gonna be a lot faster than
well Moore's law getting get back to
that again we've talked about that here
many times
yeah
so if I'm compiling a C program down to
a capability instruction set can that be
done without full program analysis can
you do it
file by file would seem that there would
be ways to do pointer arithmetic within
one file that would look like integer
did you need the full full program
analysis in the sense the hardware
supports typed objects with meta content
and one function and I returned it to
another function and then you that then
uses it as a pointer right so that
arithmetic could violate the cable yeah
yeah okay okay that's prevented good
good question I'm sorry I misinterpreted
it other questions over here
some combination of our friends at
Shenzhen and DEF CON puts the relevant
controller into a thing that looks an
awful lot like a USB plug so it's
already out there ready to to build into
whatever peripheral device you want with
the USB thing so it's just access to the
i/o bus that's the problem from
something you think is a charger or
microphone or headphones or something
else once we give it access to
this is really simplistic based on year
2000 or so knowledge of the technology
but when the device is identified can't
an appropriately small portion of the
address space be allocated to it without
causing a bust time now that was hard it
was programmed into the GIC that it only
had access to certain registers which
were the the card reader input the card
punch output and if each device had its
own allocated shared register in real
memory ok that was all programmed into
the GOC and there were three versions of
the GI OC every every 5 years think him
up with an even better version so that
got lost completely in in the hardware
business did not get carried through
that is correct and each other but it's
like the buffer overflow solution in
multics in 65 which never got carried
through and I don't want to harp on that
but having just come back from the
memorial service for Corbett Oh a lot of
discussion of what happened back then
that's a wonderful government
just came up with the best mistakes so
no nobody can top them so okay now there
are other problems here and sort of
getting back to question there's a lot
of programming problems relating to
capabilities I think you've been around
capabilities for many many years 20 I
did one in 1973 which is which was 40
and the programming problems are pretty
nasty but you want to hide that and the
beauty of the cherry LLVM is that it
hides all of this even C++ stuff if you
deal with with pointers properly and
again I said I don't I'm interested in
what happens if you if you try to do
something with with a memory safe
language you still have a lot of
opportunity would it be to make Linux
run on cherry and does Linus have any
appetite for it - even knows what what
we're doing I think some of our would be
transition partners would do that in an
instant they would say yeah they've got
to have Linux on it and I think the fact
that we're using LLVM cherry LLVM would
soften the difficulty there was there is
in the version 7 architecture document a
question that was posed what if we put
this on x86 and you're smiling the
answer is you don't want to do that but
if you were there's a there's a lovely
lovely chapter in the version 7 document
by John Baldwin
was an old FreeBSD guy and who's worked
x86 a great deal of this consulting life
and he actually detailed it in
considerable detail what would you have
to do to to do a cherry version of of
x86 that would also change your your
your approach to Karl's approach to
having Linux running on it I think again
people say why do we use MIPS the answer
was it's open source and it was
available and we had had a formal
specification of a 32-bit version of it
it was easy to extend to 64 no I think
the programming problems are things that
are on our list of things we've got to
deal with and in fact we have done a bit
in the last few years yeah there's a lot
of work being done with oak app
languages now that javascript is
essentially object capability language
and in particular sales force between
Salesforce and their business partners
and customers there are 50,000
programmers writing Oh cap applications
so maybe there's a community you can
learn from okay we have a student some
of my questions about capabilities
I guess I'm deriving from conventional
architecture where you have this role
pointers and every member axis is
protected by a page table going from
that to capabilities it basically you
place all the permissions distributed Li
with each pointer and I guess I don't
understand how it is safer with that
compared with you can have a finer like
fine
grins on the control X's with a more
finer grain some page table for example
why do you need to just store everything
distributed a with pointers instead of
having a centralized control in short
memory interesting question what one is
you've got the typing and and you can't
switch integers to two pointers you can
the other is that you can't manipulate
the capability it is it is ironclad and
unfortunately and unalterable and and
tagged so the tags allow you to have
some sort of control over the flow of
capabilities and what they can do
Pyrrha which is a programming problem
isn't it the compiler you can see
generating sloppy code that all sorts of
horrible things can happen too because
it's not memory safe our stuff is
essentially a memory safe yes I guess um
it is memory safe because you can um uh
have better control over it small region
of memory how the kids would buy a and
use a program rate
I mean why cannot be implemented by a
better page table which allows more more
more kinds of permission control and
probably over smaller regions rather
than like four kilobyte pages and also
page tables are also not for chable or
or changeable if you if your trustee or
operating system right so why does do
you need to record some redundant
information with each pointer for
example if you have a linked list then I
mean all those informations must be
duplicated
different architecture I should point
out that there are as many different
types of capability systems as people
who have been working on them some some
people have got three or four of them in
their lifetime that are different and
they're all different our capabilities
are somewhat different from from all the
others they don't move around a lot
they're they're within but you're so in
order to be memory safe and not have
dangling references basically don't you
really need a garbage collector and will
that okay and and a relocating garbage
collector well you can move Friday last
week on this problem it's now under
review it will some day see the light of
day if it gets accepted
if not we'll continue to revise it and
keep submitting it until it gets accept
but there's a there's a lot of stuff on
cherry it's called cherry revoke cherry
book rather sorry and voke cherry cherry
book but you won't find it online yet
but you will be very happy when you see
it and i'm not gonna get into details on
that what is the moment that still in
flux yeah
I'll be brief I have a comment Peter you
asked you posited the question will the
work that you've done on both cherry and
the IO attachment be adopted my
prediction is no it will not be adopted
as you have done it but the work that
you have done will be very very
influential and I encourage you to keep
socializing the work you've done because
I think it's it could be very very
helpful and I think our relationship
with arm for example they're not going
to use exactly what we give them and I
think some of the other folks were
talking with will do the same we're
trying to do that yeah as I said we've
got 56 papers or something like that in
9 years this is wonderful thank you so
much I guess that's the end of the day
[Applause]